so i want to start today by talking
about gay republicans gay republicans at
one point thought hey you know what
they're going to accept us in the
republican party gay marriage is now
legal it's kind of becoming a non-issue
and if we are for low taxes if we are
for low regulation if we
are about christian values whatever that
means at the time that they say it
within the context of the republican
party the republican party will accept
us because it's moved on to other things
and unfortunately uh punctuated with
last week's vote against marriage
equality from 157 different republicans
in the house of representatives it is
now abundantly clear that gay
republicans have failed
at being integrated into the republican
party the republican party is seeing a
sort of resurgence of overt homophobia
now it's important to understand that
overt is the key word
the homophobia never went away from the
republican party there was this moment
after gay marriage was legalized and
donald trump became the republican
nominee where donald trump would say
he's fine with uh gay people and gay
marriage and just kind of look the other
way it's a non-issue and quite frankly
on a personal level i think trump
doesn't care at all about gay marriage i
think he's just it's not even an issue
he really cares about
but slowly but surely and we're going to
talk about this in the next segment as
the christian element of the republican
party has become more overtly
nationalistic and by that i don't mean
they happen to be christians and they
are nationalists i mean they are
christian nationalists specifically
as the trans issue
has gotten good
uh has made headway in re-igniting
some of these visceral cultural issues
social issues for republicans they've
sort of been drawn back to
the base fundamental homophobia that was
a critical part of the republican party
for a long time but
acutely at the end of the george w bush
era and during the barack obama era
there has been
there was a period of time on the show
where we would much more regularly cover
the overt homophobia school homophobia
from the republican party in the bush
era and in the obama era of the david
pakman show
we were often talking about the
outrageous homophobic tirades on the
floor of the house and on various talk
radio programs by right-wing republicans
it was a much more common thing and in
the trump era there was far less of it
now i'm not saying all of a sudden the
republican party was enlightened on gay
rights that's not what i'm saying at all
what i'm saying is they were less
overtly homophobic because they moved on
to other things including the trans
issue it's important to mention well
very interesting article now in the
texas tribune we failed gay republicans
who fought for acceptance in the texas
republican party see little prog
progress gay republicans who have fought
for acceptance within the texas gop over
the past three decades told the texas
tribune progress has been excruciatingly
slow that's quite an understatement many
of them have left the party even as the
number of log cabin republicans in texas
continues to grow log cabin republicans
is a gay republican group
um and the article sort of tells the
story of how there was this
um a period of time i guess we would say
after the aids crisis
uh where there was the idea that listen
uh we're gay but we want low taxes and
we want low regulation and we're
christian family values whatever and the
republican party is a big tent and
they'll welcome us probably as long as
we have donor dollars and there may have
been a brief period of time where it
seemed like that was a plausible thing
but it has stopped
and um fundamentally what this comes
down to is
there is a group of milli
mostly wealthy white gay men
who think will be accepted as the good
guys as long as we more or less say the
right things they might not love us but
they'll look the other way about
being gay
and will be part of the trump gop they
were never really going to be welcomed
into the george w bush gop
during the obama era it was this kind of
transitional phase and then the trump
gop might welcome us but it turns out
that they don't and it's a very similar
thing to caitlyn jenner caitlyn jenner
great caitlyn jenner republican
doesn't like woke
whatever she understands that to me
doesn't like uh liberals and all this
stuff but then gets booed out of cpac
because of course she did
of course she did and it would sort of
be funny
if it wasn't tragic on multiple levels
i'll tell you what some of those levels
are one level on which the continued
homophobia and transphobia of the
republican party is tragic is that it's
2022
and when you have a duopoly in the
united states there's two major parties
when one of those parties in 2022
remains openly transphobic and
homophobic you see how retrograde and
recalcitrant the country is if you look
at some other countries every country
has homophobia don't get me wrong but
there are countries including some
countries in europe some countries in
south america to a lesser degree with
multi-party systems where you might have
you know six major parties and five
are very much on the same page like
listen of course gay people can get
married of course nobody should be able
to get fired for their real or pursue
perceived sexual orientation and then
you've got like one homophobic party in
the united states we have a duopoly
and one of the two parties
is still
basically overtly homophobic you have
some republicans who are like listen
it's a decided issue it's not like
they're going to cheer gay marriage it's
not like they're going to cheer not
being able to fire people because you
believe that they're gay but they'll say
it's a decided issue and we're moving on
to other things um but it is very
retrograde so that's one level on which
it is tragic the second level on which
it's tragic is the republicans who are
gay who are desperate to be accepted
into this party that just doesn't want
them and they'll probably take their
money in most cases
under not protest but sort of like
turning their nose you you would say
um
but they're not gonna like it and that's
sad as well because listen there's
nothing wrong with being gay and wanting
low taxes and thinking low taxes are the
right thing that that
okay you know people have different
views about what the level of taxation
should be
but
overall the republican party is this
movement that's much more than just low
taxes it's much more than just low
regulation it is increasingly
a fundamentalist christian nationalist
worldview
reactionary in ways that they don't even
fully understand and you'll see some
examples of that later in the show when
we look at the new alex jones conspiracy
theories that even his followers don't
get but it's like it sort of sounds okay
and it's tragic on that level as well
but that's what it is and it seems at
this point the movement for
the gay republicans to be integrated
into the republican party not going
particularly well
tomorrow on the show we're going to
spend some time talking about the overt
christian nationalist movement and the
republican party now
is overtly christian nationalist are
they're straight up saying we're sick of
this separation of church and state
stuff we're sick of all of it
uh but i want to give you another data
point in this today before we do our
bigger story on it tomorrow marjorie
taylor greene among others spoke at the
turning point usa event over the weekend
we're going to look at more clips of
this we'll look at trump's speech and
don jr's speech and lauren baubert
saying i never was an escort i never was
a prostitute for ted cruz really weird
weird event but before we get into that
in more detail there was this one moment
where marjorie taylor green said
christian nationalism is great that's
what we need uh let's take a look at
this video clip and then we'll discuss
perfect it just means we're doing the
right thing
and i think that's what the republican
party needs to be about
i'm a christian how many christians do
we have here
so you see i also call myself a
christian nationalist
and that's not a bad word
that's actually a good thing right and
there's nothing wrong with leading with
your in with your faith because we
should lead with our faith because if
we're doing that then we're doing the
right thing doesn't mean we're perfect
it just means we're doing the right
thing so she says that that's what the
republican party should be about now
christian nationalism is not just
we happen to be christian and
we like the united states or whatever
christian nationalism means you believe
united states as a nation
is defined by christianity
government should be actively
keeping the united states a christian
nation
uh the united states government should
be
imposing or prioritizing or giving
preference to christianity there should
be
christianity should be the doctrine a
prescriptive doctrine for how the
government runs and you're sort of
breaking down separation of church and
state this is not unique to marjorie
taylor green that the belief that
christianity should be privileged in the
public square remember we've looked at
clips of lauren bobert lauren bobert
openly is calling for the same thing now
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation
and christians will begin to position
themselves
in these days and these times that
pastors would have a boldness to speak
from the pulpit of their churches to
direct and inform the church on how to
influence the direction of government
so that's pretty full on and if that's
not direct enough for you here she was
saying she's tired of this separation of
church and state stuff we looked at this
about a month ago when it took place the
reason we had so many over-reaching
regulations in our nation is because the
church complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does now i've told you before
that she's wrong in fact when they say
it was in a stinking letter what they're
trying to do is minimize the idea the
desire for separation of church and
state to like an offhanded casual letter
written by thomas jefferson that's what
lauren bobert wants you to believe she
wants you to believe it's all mis it's
all a big mistake there was no actual
desire for separation of church and
state thomas jefferson sort of mentioned
it in one letter and that's it but the
reality is that were they deists or not
were they christians or not
the founding fathers very clearly
recognized and it's established in the
constitution
that there should be no prioritization
of one religion over another nor of
religion over non-religion in the united
states it's abundantly clear the fact
that we're going back to that you know
we one of the things republicans love to
do is they don't just want to go back to
the 1950s they also want to go back to
debates that have been long settled and
that anybody who takes them seriously
realizes there actually is no debate
about um and this is extraordinarily
dangerous so we're going to talk
tomorrow on the on the show
uh about the decidedly christian
nationalist move of the republican party
not everybody in the republican party
agrees with it i mean someone like adam
kinzinger he doesn't agree with it he's
also retiring and is kind of
increasingly irrelevant within the party
but even trump now is regularly at his
rallies and we might look at the clip
later saying we we kneel only before god
and all of these different sort of
signals to the christian nationalists so
this is a very dangerous movement in
particular because if they do well in
november and then they control the 2024
election there are all sorts of ways in
which they can impose this christianity
in the public square completely
antithetical
i mean without a doubt completely
antithetical to what the framers wanted
so we will talk about it more and in the
meantime you can send me your thoughts
by finding me on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so donald trump did a rally for arizona
republican candidate kerry lake on
friday evening he was hours late he was
dripping wet the entire speech it was
one of the absolute strangest speeches
that he gave and trump was booed at his
own rally
and his reaction is so telling about
what matters to him we will get to that
let's go through some of these clips
again trump finally taking the stage
dripping wet barely audible at moments
his voice almost completely gone and he
one of the first claims trump makes when
he takes the stage is that gas currently
costs
nine
dollars per gallon ago when i was in
office
yes gasoline nothing called gasoline now
nobody wants to even talk about it was
1.87 cents a gallon
and now it's five
six
seven and even in some places eight and
nine dollars a
gallon i love the people nodding in the
background as if they know that to be
true when it's obviously not true now
just about everything trump says about
gas prices is a lie one of the things
that trump said was that it was 187 when
he left it wasn't it was more like 220
but gas prices are now down dramatically
in fact gas prices if you look they
peaked at 502
in mid-june we are now about five and a
half closing in on six weeks of steady
declines down to about 428
or so a gallon the highest price in the
country on average is california at 574.
the lowest is texas at 387 high but not
super dramatic so just it it's all lies
trump then claims he finished the border
wall now this is funny because trump in
speeches says both that
if you if he gets the opportunity again
they're going to finish the border wall
and also that it's done illegal aliens
and gang members
and we built hundreds of miles of border
wall
in fact we completely finished our
original plan
despite two and a half years of democrat
inspired lawsuits now remember that the
plan was a border wall across the entire
us
mexico i mean i'm exhausted at this
point
it was the whole border that was the
promise it was a first term promise
and they added like 90 miles or
something like that trump also with his
continued delusions of grandeur claiming
that he saved merry christmas
remember i said we're going to save
christmas merry christmas we saved merry
christmas didn't we the department store
said don't buy if they don't have
merry christmas they were
told it's not good
they want to get rid of christopher
columbus but more importantly merry
christmas but they say merry christmas
again don't they right a whole different
thing this is what i call dumb red meat
it's an attempt to be red meat but
instead of being the type of stuff we
used to see like about welfare queens or
whatever the case may be it's just
dumb red meat um this was maybe one of
the most fascinating moments in the
speech trump and deus endor hindust
endorse this guy named blake masters and
the crowd booed and then what's
fascinating is trump goes you still like
me right and at the end of the day
that's what he cares about and a highly
respected man just endorsed by me today
future congressman for the second
district eli crane oh sorry this isn't
the blake masters moment this is the eli
crane moment okay still debut now
thank you
[Applause]
but you like me right okay
and that is a throwaway line but that's
the truth trump doesn't really care
whether he helps these people that he
endorses beyond how it reflects on him
if it's a win in his endorsement record
that he touts great
if you don't even like the person he
endorses and you don't vote for them
fine as long as you still like trump
trump then pulling out the victim card
saying no one no one has been through
what he's been through and as a post
office a post uh post-presidency
president he's supposed to be having a
great life now not embroiled in all
sorts of scandals who has been through
anything like what i've been through
seriously
who
certainly no politician and
definitely no president a president
leaves office and
it's supposed to be a wonderful life
and all this while i was doing so much
as
president including the most secure
border in american history isn't it sad
guys just truly truly a victim
uh many of you also noticed that
they during trump's speech it sort of
seemed like they swapped out the black
people that are on stage behind trump
this is like a tried and true staple of
trump speeches which is trump has almost
no black supporters i mean when you look
at the numbers almost no black
supporters but there's always black
supporters up on the stage behind trump
it was notable
that there was a particular black guy
over trump's right shoulder at the start
of the speech and he did seem to be
swapped out with a different uh trump
supporting black guy i can't tell you
any more about it other than a bunch of
you noticed it and wrote to me about it
trump then denied the claim made by
cassidy hutchinson under oath to the
january 6 committee that he threw
ketchup at the wall
then they had me throwing food
throwing food in the white house i don't
throw food in the water i don't throw
food anywhere
i eat the food which is a problem i'd
probably be better off if i threw it
yeah i think the next time i should
throw it i won't eat it i'll be much
better off but i'm throwing food in the
way
and remember everybody who was going to
come forward and under oath dispute the
claims of cassidy hutchinson they
haven't shown up and we're going to talk
about that tomorrow trump referring to
his son don jr as just a good kid who's
getting a bad rap don jr is a 44 year
old adult with multiple children uh but
he's a good kid trump says think of it
to tell you how bad a person is right
so
adam schiff is a sleazeball everybody
knows not a dumb person by the way you
know we're not dealing with dummies but
he's a sleazeball you take a look
perfect watermelon head you know
and he's angry with biden because he was
supposed to get a job in the
administration and they didn't want him
but he goes up he's a smart guy goes up
to the microphones thank you thank you
very much this is a third day for
america
donald trump jr
has a relationship with russia
and the you know they know it's a big
deal because they're they're more faith
than adam chev
and they're all going click click click
now think of this just think of this
here's a young guy don jr is a good kid
isn't that something i mean
it's kafka-esque
a staple of trump speeches now is this
anti-trans line
that no teacher should be allowed to
teach transgender we still don't know
what that means
and no teachers should ever be allowed
to teach
transgender to our children without
parental constraints right you need a
permission slip to be taught transgender
i still don't even know what that means
another classic of trump rallies is when
trump calls you up to speak if you're
the person he's endorsing
you had better be quick and mostly
praise trump if you start talking about
policy when trump calls you up you see
trump immediately glaze over these
cultists know exactly how to do it right
well thank you mr president i really
just wanted to thank you
for saving this country
do you agree with me did president trump
literally save this country
[Music]
well right you so there it is he knows
exactly the right way to do it uh
complete and total cult then carrie lake
came up another trump and dorsey
um and she just straight up refers to
trump as superman
this is how
you have to placate the petulant child
or he will flip out and get bored
and i think arizona is your favorite
state you don't have to say but i think
arizona is his favorite state
president trump taught us how to fight
and i took a few notes
that's why i go after the fake news
because he showed us how to do it he
gave us the game plan and he showed us
exactly how to stand up and fight and
republicans need to fight back
now you'll notice trump's already kind
aboard
now listen we can't sit back and wait
for superman to come
come in and rescue us right now
we can't wait for superman to rescue us
right now
we have to stand up we've got to vote
we've got to get active we have to make
sure we tell our friends to vote
and we have to be
running for office running for school
board each and every one of us has to
get involved use your god given gifts
and get involved to save this country
now i want to say for the record
for the record i do believe that
superman is coming back and hopefully
he's coming back soon
there you go uh so there is the i mean
this is a complete and total cult and
then last thing trump
goes on a weird tangent about executing
drug dealers
and that finally gets the crowd cheering
we're going to stop this scourge it's
time to get by the way it's the word is
scourge and he continues to not be able
to say
brutally tough on the dealers
traffickers in the narco terrorist
cartels who are stealing millions and
millions of lives we lose 200 and 250
000 lives a year
and i heard a statistic that each drug
dealer will kill during a period of 10
to 15 years
anywhere from 20 to 50 people and the
bigger ones killed hundreds and hundreds
of people what when i was with president
xi of china
i said you have a drug problem
rather naively
no
no why do you ask he couldn't understand
the question
i said why don't you have a drug prep
well we have quick trial
what's a quick trial
quick trial is if they are dealing drugs
they have a quick trial
and they're executed immediately
we don't have a
quick trial system crowd likes that
[Applause]
and i see it all the time and i have a
lot of friends they're wonderful people
they all want to be on the committees
and we call them blue ribbon committees
headed up by nice people wonderful
people okay so anyway another one of
these bizarre events the crowd very very
bored after waiting hours for a late
trump and uh the cult continues and
unfortunately he gets the crowds and if
he decides to run for 2024 he has a very
very good shot so let's go from the
rally to the turning point usa event on
the following day we are now going to
look uh in this segment and in the next
segment at some of the speeches at the
turning point usa student summit okay
this was in tampa florida now we're
going to start with donald trump's wwe
style entrance to the summit and i know
that you're going to see this and you're
going to cringe and when i see it i
cringe but just remember the left
doesn't have anything like this the
right engages people with this stuff
it's so stupid and it's so fundamentally
vapid
but they fund stuff to activate people
they fun stuff to get people excited and
we just fail on the left take a look at
this introduction for trump
and i fight harder for you than any
president has ever fought again
we will win again we will win win-win
you're fired
the most loyal people are trump
supporters because they like
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're not
and i fight harder for you than any
president has ever before
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna make america great again i
love you thank you thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen
please welcome the 45th president of the
united states of america
donald j
trump
[Music]
okay and there's pyrotechnics going and
eventually trump comes out so listen
it's a complete and total joke but they
know how to engage people they're
getting young people engaged and unless
the left figures out how to fund stuff
like this and how to effectively
coalesce people
around candidates and ideas uh it's not
looking particularly good now on the
substance the speech that trump gave to
the turning point usa people was
completely unhinged at one point trump
said he wanted to give himself the
congressional medal of honor
in fact as president i wanted to give
myself the congressional medal of honor
but they wouldn't let me do it
they wouldn't let me do it i said i'm
going to give myself a kick i've always
wanted that
but they wouldn't let me do that they
said that would be inappropriate i said
okay it would look bad for trump to do
that one of the most uh stunning things
trump will sometimes do is he will tell
stories about flying on private jets
either his own or air force one and uh
not exactly relatable to most people in
the crowd but trump's audience here in
florida sat silently as trump told the
bizarre rambling story about air force
one just really not reading the room you
can't believe it you know air force one
is actually two planes it's two big
747s
so they were ordered
but we're on the plane flying over
and we're about an hour away from the
big airfield that we're landing in in
iraq
and i get a
call and then some military people came
in to see me you know this is like a a
large home
air force one very big a lot of people
on the plane most talented people you've
ever seen including the pilots the most
incredible people
sir
would you please do us a favor we'd like
to close all of your windows i say why
we don't want any light on the plane i
said why is that because we don't want
the enemy to see us think of it we've
been there for 20 years and we can't fly
an airplane into the contract
i said that's pretty sad
so they closed down all of the shades
everything was absolutely dark and they
say sir we're going to be turning off
the lights and the plane i said what do
you have to do that we just closed all
the shades and the windows he really has
a way with words i mean just a riveting
absolutely riveting storyteller as you
can see
donald trump claimed that nursing home
residents really don't don't vote that
much because they're very busy dying
wisconsin they said nursing home the
nursing home scandal nursing homes
typically don't vote too much you know
people are dying
they got other things in their mind
but they got almost a hundred percent of
the people in nursing homes yes so trump
very confused about what goes on in
nursing homes and then trump began
playing up the victim stuff saying he's
the most persecuted person in american
history again another part of the speech
that the crowd was silent during a
friend of mine recently said
that i was the most persecuted person in
the history of our country me the most
persecuted i never thought it that way i
never had time i was always fighting
with these people that were trying to
persecute me
i didn't have time to think about being
persecuted because i was fighting
persecution
when i thought about it though i sit
back he's a very smart guy successful
i thought set back i said you know
he may very well be right
certainly there's been no politician or
president treated like i've been treated
right no one's been treated worse than
trump as he continues to remind us then
the christian nationalist moment of the
speech we're going to talk about this
more tomorrow in general the republican
party going in this christian
nationalist direction trump again with
this americans kneel before god and god
alone we will not break we will not
yield we will never give in
we will never give up
we will never ever ever back down
as long as we are confident in united
the tyrants we are fighting
do not stand a chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone
right
and that is another allusion to the
christian nationalism of the modern
republican party and then trump capping
off his speech to these young
conservatives
with uh some transphobia that's a big
part now of every uh trump speech you
can't teach the bible but you can teach
children that america is evil and that
men can get pregnant a man can get
pregnant
[Applause]
can't even talk about the bible
you would not trust these people to
babysit your children for 20 minutes
and why should we then
let them educate millions of american
students six hours a day year after year
after year and then also trump
misgendering trans people and goading
the crowd into booing them this is
another staple of the trump speech
in a very sad state it already is our
country's never been in a position like
this before happened all in a short
period of time
across the united states we need to
implement strict prohibitions on
teaching inappropriate racial
sexual and political material to
america's children in any form
[Applause]
we will also keep men out of women's
sports is that okay
right
notice how fired up the crowd gets i
mean they've convinced these people in
the crowd
that that transports issue is like an
issue of paramount importance in the
united states
think about it
[Applause]
now i've told the story a number of
times you know the
swimmer with a man's body you know they
say that they describe it that way they
say uh
no uh he's on the swim team he was given
women athlete of the year
so
oh you didn't hear i guess see so pretty
pretty sick stuff and very interesting
that now
interesting and disgusting that now the
transphobia is just a staple of when
trump speaks to crowds so
we will pause there
you can fi if you're if you're so
inclined you can find all these clips on
our instagram at david pakman show after
the break we'll look at what some of the
other speakers said and we need to be
this these events can't be ignored
because as sick as they are
the right knows exactly what they're
doing and the left is doing nothing so
we'll be right back with more from tampa
florida
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right let's
continue our tour of the insanity that
was the turning point usa student event
in tampa florida they really get the
students fired up this is a full on
indoctrination type event this is the
type of thing you would imagine is
taking place uh done by the government
of north korea for example and the we
we've actually seen and talked about
such events in north korea one of the
we've already looked at what donald
trump said one of the other speakers was
donald trump jr now we've seen a lot of
video of donald trump jr
i have never seen him this wired
and of course the speculation is that he
is on some kind of upper
there are different opinions as to what
upper that is
uh i will sort of stop my analysis there
but um making very very little sense
really hopped up sped up and and this
video is not sped up importantly
like i've never seen it like she can do
like a half an hour and like there's
like three words
no it's
it's like i don't know whether to be
like upset or impressed
you know
it's like the crazy crap that hillary
was saying last week she was like yeah
that's perfect here
kamala is your speech writer
camilla like that's next
and the only thing scarier again than
perhaps jill biden would be come up yeah
so this is his anti-kamala rant don jr
then moving on to claiming covet
variants are invented conspiracy
theories and all sorts of other stuff
that should should get you put in a
loony bin quite frankly and i know that
that's not a politically correct term it
should make us question one's sanity but
the crowd loves it the crowd cheers this
is a crowd where this stuff is rewarded
remember folks
the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth
it used to be about six months right
was there anything all the things we've
been talking about has there been one
that we were wrong about
in the end meaning we were told we were
wrong we were canceled if you were a
doctor and you questioned clown fouchy
uh you know you were thrown out of the
medical profession
any one of those things
ah turns out they were right huh it
doesn't matter we got what we wanted
let's move on
the difference is now it's like six
minutes right between
what your label conspiracy theory turns
out to be the truth they can't hide
anymore because it's compounding so
badly
it just doesn't stop
and we're gonna see this more right
we're either going to have a midterm
variant obviously right right
so they can implement whatever they need
to do fraudulent voting and whatever it
may be
or you're seeing
you guys are seeing it
you know it's coming
the monkey pox pandemic folks
this is another one which again they the
they're they're taking both sides of the
monkey pox stuff
where on the one hand they're starting
to say
covet clearly was some kind of concocted
psyop because now we've got monkey pox
and nobody's saying we gotta shut down
because of monkey pox that proves
something about covet was fake it's like
well though cove it's a respiratory
virus it spreads extraordinarily easily
monkey pox is spreading through physical
contact sexual contact skin to skin
so
the transmission is completely different
so why would the reaction be the same
but at the same time they're starting to
say
monkey pox is being set up to do the
same thing that they did they did with
covid so they'll have it both ways on
all of these things uh one other kind of
funny moment was now don jr is rewriting
history about when trump had to be
helped down that ramp by uh by a general
remember when trump
walked down a ramp it was like raining
and slippery so he held onto the
banister and it was like he's in the
later stages of dementia and alzheimer's
combined
he is literally about to drop dead oh my
god 25th amendment now it was actually
uh not raining that day it was sunny and
i went back just because i was like am i
misremembering the day that trump walked
down the ramp it was a beautiful sunny
day at the time that donald trump walked
down with his hand held by the general
doesn't change anything one way or the
other not a big deal but they're just
straight up rewriting history at this
point and the crowd loves it now last
thing donald trump also has evidence
that he is being suppressed and that the
right is being suppressed which is his
posts don't get as many likes as they
used to
have you ever noticed it only goes one
way
yeah like you know
i'm getting like 10 000 likes a post
from like 300 000 like couple months ago
because
they don't like me right now right if
you're effective they're gonna suppress
you we are working that much harder
yeah so that's the new proof that of
course there is some
subterfuge at play don jr is getting
fewer likes so the crowd loves it don jr
is hopped up as i've ever seen him and
the hits just came coming next is uh
lauren bober so uh radical repugnant
republican congresswoman lauren beaubert
or bo bear depending on your preference
spoke at the turning point event over
the weekend in tampa florida
she apropos of seemingly nothing
although there actually is a backstory
but nobody knew it she denied being a
prostitute for ted cruz now it's not
clear whether she means that ted cruz
was her pimp and that's what she's
denying or that ted cruz was the john
and that's what she's denying i don't
know which she's denying but she is
denying it check this out this is a
congresswoman folks about ted cruz
lately in the news
and contrary to popularity belief
i have never been an escort
for senator ted cruz
but i will tell you tonight it is the
coolest thing i've ever heard about ted
cruz
the
she was not a prostitute for ted cruz
and whether that means with ted cruz as
the client or ted cruz as the pimp
but regardless uh it would be cool if
ted cruz was doing that i guess it's all
very strange now this actually does
relate to something this story did not
get a lot of attention it was the story
was pitched to me and i didn't cover it
because the sourcing on it was sketchy
and just didn't make sense to cover it
there was a group that made claims about
lauren beaubert including that she was
an escort or prostitute and it was not
um you know when when i looked at it it
didn't look like lauren bober in the
picture and indeed cnn said the woman in
the picture is not bo bear and there
were all sorts of other incorrect claims
made but it was not really a widely
known story
so
her bringing up and saying listen let me
just tell you i was not an escort okay
just kind of a weird moment one other uh
kind of interesting moment
is uh when lauren beaubert put together
a very strange word salad that was
completely unintelligible see if you can
make heads or tails out of this
position yourself for this newness this
newness that we are coming into
we are going to take our country back
together we are not drawing back we are
pressing in every single day that's why
you're here
getting equipped for this right if you
can understand that
please email me and explain to me what
she's saying about positioning yourself
for the new ness the newness the
new-ness
crazy crazy conference and the crowd
will cheer for anything
after the break we'll look at one more
clip from this event from matt gates and
then move on to other things stay with
us we'll be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
all right one more clip this is the last
one from the turning point usa event to
try to indoctrinate young people into
right-wing reactionary thinking this is
republican congressman matt gates he has
an idea he says that the only women who
are in favor of abortion being a choice
are the women who would never need an
abortion because they're too ugly for
anyone to impregnate them to begin with
which is an interesting interesting
theory for him to be making take a
listen to this have you watched
these pro-abortion pro-murder rallies
the people
are just disgusting
like why is it
that
the women with the least likelihood of
getting pregnant are the ones most
worried about having abortions
nobody wants to impregnate you if you
look like a thumb
these people are odious on the inside
and out they're like five to
350 pounds and they're like give me my
abortions or i'll get up in march and
protest and i'm thinking marge
you look like you got ankles weaker than
the legal reasoning behind roe versus
wade
a few of them need to get up in march
they need to get up and march for like
an hour a day swing those arms get the
blood pumping maybe mix in a salad now
as absurd as this is if it were true
there would be no demand for abortion
services right i mean like it's it's so
stupid and of course it you know
it's fat phobic it's it's it's
misogynistic it's everything if only
women who no one would have sex with
want abortions there would by definition
be no abortion so it's by definition not
true
and even after
this tirade after this disgusting tirade
from a disgusting guy
women will still vote for him like it's
crazy but he will almost certainly be
re-elected and so as a reminder when you
hear the things that matt gates says and
we say that is just vile how how does
someone like this get elected it's
really horrible that he exists no no
he's not the disease he's the symptom
the disease is the people in
i forget what he represents is it the
pensacola area or whatever in florida
the the disease is
that people will vote for him despite
these comments or even because of
comments like this just a dis completely
disgusting guy and this is
sort of the new wave of republicanism i
am not
pre now
now that we've seen what took place at
this turning point usa event over the
weekend i'm not saying that i
am a supporter of the politics of the
sort of cadre of
mitt romney
john mccain
george w bush dick cheney like i'm not a
supporter of that
but there is sort of a battle for the
republican party right now where you
have on the one hand people like in the
modern day
romney and liz cheney and to a lesser
degree adam kinzinger or whoever that's
one side and then on the other side you
have
bobert green
trump
gates
those types of people
and there's no real way to know right
now
what the republican party will look like
in five years and i used the number five
specifically that would be 2027 it would
be
after these midterms and the next
presidential and one more midterm that's
three election cycles what will the
republican party look like in five years
is it going to be more
like the bush romney mccain republican
party
is it going to be an even exponentially
more cuckoo for coco puffs version of
the trumpian republican party is it
going to be a new thing altogether will
it split we don't know but when you look
at an event like turning point usa
there's none of that other type of
conservatism there there's no
conservatism at all this is really just
ignorant reactionary thinking um i don't
know what it's going to look like in
five years but it's going to be a
hellish path for the united states no
matter which way it goes hey we're going
to look at a couple clips of infowars
conspiracy theorist alex jones you guys
remember alex jones pac-man's a loser
right that guy um alex jones has some
new conspiracy theories including some
that he explained to steve bannon which
we'll get to
that are so complicated and so
ridiculous
that even his own followers don't get
them and you know what i also don't get
them because they don't make any sense
let's start with the first one it's
something about count dracula
the operating system of the saks coburg
gotha
families right which is the oldest
bloodline
of european bloodlines in the world in
which all european bloodlines
agree are their progenitors
going back to their founder
vlad the impaler
count dracula is the recognized head of
the entire dynasty there you go
and so this house of the dragon that
flies the dragon banner the dracul
rule the planet
just like revelation tells us the dragon
and
it's allied with the other dragon the
chakoms
and its goal is
the operating system uh chewbacca
reportedly also plays a pretty major
role
in this one
um
it doesn't even sound like alex jones
understands what he's talking about here
uh in this next clip he actually he
being alex jones actually interviewed
steve bannon hot off of his conviction
and he tries to explain
one of these crazy globalist conspiracy
theories to steve bannon globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron okay that
was actually me okay but here's the
actual alex jones uh explanation to
bannon say no no this is good you need
pain booty judges said and and and
grand home and all of them we're doing
this in transition but it's not a
transition into a better star trek
civilization it's a transition into a
new feudal estate literally cutting off
the energy to make everybody poor and
dumb down feudalism 2.0
and so that's that's what the great
reset is that's what klaus schwab is
that's what this professor of medieval
studies harare is none of those are his
ideas that's all been said by the club
of rome it's all been said by the
bilderberg group it's all been said by
limits to growth you know it's all been
said by the population mom it's all been
said in ecoscience uh you know written
in the 70s uh but by the man that later
became obama's uh you know science czar
and when you read this stuff if you just
sit back and look at it you go this is
the closest thing to hitler i've ever
seen just sit back guys this is like
hitler
5.0 this is like hitler buck rogers
level right the other funny thing is
alex jones acting like hitler is bad
here which is another thing you don't
necessarily always assume alex jones
will say okay so here's one more and in
this one this is now back to alex jones
show and he says in this one that the
attack has started the popul the
depopulation has started there's a
second atlantis happening and something
about nanotechnology and they're going
to take the food and they're going to
wipe everybody out why it's never clear
it's here the second atlantis
and you know how atlantis ended
and america was founded
by francis bacon and others
to be the new atlantis
and so that's where we are and the
decision has been made and you can see
the arguments are there especially the
public doesn't say no to this this is a
test
to go ahead and wipe out
90 plus percent of the population
and quite frankly if the population
doesn't care it doesn't get engaged
doesn't get involved
the population does deserve to die the
children don't but definitely the adults
and the slavs and the decadent people
that that think they're winning in this
corrupt system and think this is all
funny those people
deserve to die
i'm not going to kill them we shouldn't
kill them
but i'm simply explaining they're
projecting their own loathing of
themselves onto us and they want us to
die do you think i mean so one question
is do you understand this but the more
important thing is do you think it's
even designed for jones audience to
understand or it's just they're supposed
to hear his confidence and the buzzwords
and go
that makes a lot of sense without even
understanding it like it arguably it's
designed not to be understood and i'm
simply telling them don't worry you're
not going to have to wait long you're
going to be in a dystopia and die too
so go ahead and pretend like you're part
of the power structure you're not but
then there's the real luciferians right
on top
who actually believe lucifer's god
they're bringing balance the universe
and they're very sad about what they
have to do and this is all part of a
greater plan they're instruments of this
uh incredible
transformation that they call it
this transcendence that's happening
so
they've already begun injecting people
with the time delayed kill switches yep
uh it's they're already spraying us with
nanotech already putting in all the food
it's the attack has begun yep and uh so
that kill switch basically you get
injected with the kill switch or uh you
eat it and then at any point someone can
basically flip a switch maybe klaus
schwab or you know often the people who
have this access to the switch are jews
in these conspiracy theories um they can
just flip the switch and kill you when
you're no longer useful to them and as
you notice there's a lot of vague them
and they in all of these hypotheses and
that is all completely by design um
again we don't make fundamental illness
we don't stigmatize it but these are the
sorts of paranoid delusions that you
would often look at medication for and
it is a guy who has built an audience
around it extremely scary stuff we have
a voicemail number and that number is
219 to david p
we uh last week i told you joe biden's
approval rating is low
and some people actually became furious
with me because of that
this voicemail is a parody of those
people i'll tell you more about it in a
moment
hello this is alan from jersey i'm so
outraged that you david how dare you
report accurate information on joe
biden's approval rating we need you to
lie and distort exactly the same as fox
news does except on the left so when fox
news lies and distorts about trump you
need to lie in distort about biden you
can't admit the truth about his approval
ratings i'm so outraged at you telling
the truth that i've had to sign up for
10 to 15 memberships just so i can
cancel 10 to 15 memberships in
disapproval it's exactly like flushing a
toilet you need to do it 10 to 15 times
okay now this guy is joking but in all
seriousness i mentioned this on a stream
the other day i got emails after
reporting that joe biden's approval
rating is low now that's not my opinion
of joe biden and it's not my poll i'm
just report i've reported to people
when george w bush was president i would
tell you his approval and when obama was
president i would tell you his approval
and when trump was president i would
tell you his approval now i tell you joe
biden's approval which is low guys it's
low i'm not going to lie to you and i
had one person write in saying what
david uh
you're mad that biden hasn't given
everybody a pony like no that story
wasn't about my opinion that story was
what is his approval rating
other people saying i shouldn't be
poisoning the well by mentioning that
his approval rating is low what does
that even mean
what are you talking about are you
saying i should hide information or lie
to the audience it's crazy and yes a
handful of people cancelled memberships
because i said hey guys joe biden's
approval rating isn't doing so well
this is what i'm talking about
the right spends a weekend funding a
glitzy event with pyrotechnics making
stars out of their lunatic politicians
coalescing activity and activism and and
energy and meanwhile over here like
david you mentioned biden's approval
rating
i'm canceling my five dollar a month
membership it's concerning stuff
said it before it's very concerning
on today's bonus show by the way the
bonus show ron desantis is now going
around saying biden stimulus caused
inflation
so they should send the money to
floridians but it's like that won't
actually change the inflationary element
of it
a students in a dallas school district
are now going to be mandated to wear
clear backpacks in order to make it
evident if there are guns in the
backpacks that's where we are
and missouri democrats after video of
republican senator josh hawley was
released of him running out of the
capital on january 6th they are doing a
holland holly 5k race
sort of making fun of josh hawley we
will talk about that and more
on today's bonus show don't miss
tomorrow evening's town hall
6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific it will be
streaming live on pacmanlive
and everybody will be welcome to call in
through the discord at davidpakman.com
discord and yes
our website members will get priority
participation on the town hall you can
sign up at joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code big voting 22 to
get a discount looking forward to seeing
everybody number one on today's bonus
show and number two during the town hall
event tomorrow see you then